-When you tell people
you have five children,
there's probably
a bit of a gasp.
-Oh, there is -- It's a gasp,
but my wife is one of nine,
and so she comes from this
insanely large family
that's very close.
They do everything together.
Like, over Christmas, I went
to a movie with 30 people.
I'm not even making that --
We were walking around.
People thought
we were from a church.
To put it in perspective,
Jesus only walked around
with 12.
And so I learned very quickly,
being married,
that I don't want to do anything
with 30 people.
Like, if I was on the "Titanic"
and the last rescue boat
was full with 30 people,
I'd be like,
"You guys go ahead.
I don't want to be there
when you try and decide
where to eat lunch."
But they're amazing.
-Are you close?
Have you become close
with her extended family?
-You know,
they're amazing people.
And my wife's parents
are special people.
Their names
are Louise and Dominic.
I call them Louise and Dom.
But my wife's siblings
have also gotten married,
and some of their spouses
call Louise and Dom
"Mom" and "Dad,"
because they're weirdos.
You know, it's like --
Like, do you call your in-laws
Mom and Dad?
-No.
-'Cause it's like --
I understand sometimes
people marry into a family,
and you become so close
to their spouse's parents
that they want to call them
Mom and Dad, but don't!
It's weird and confusing
for the rest of us.
They're like,
"Wait. That's his mom?
He married his sister?"
It's like,
"What state is he from?"
You know?
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
You have a new tour --
Quality Time Tour.
-Quality Time Tour.
-That's very exciting.
You like being on the road?
-I love it. I love it.
It's just amazing going around.
I'm going to Canada this week.
So it's a good time.
-That's great.
Well, there is --
Nobody's better at it than you.
That's why I've always liked you
more than Mulaney.
-John Mulaney.
He likes me more than you, John!
-Give it up for
Jim Gaffigan, everybody!